hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zu einer folge fort lüften
entschuldige mich schon mal für meine
stimme ich komme gerade aus berlin und
hatte allgemein die letzten tage wochen
monate nur immer sehr vier stunden
schlaf pro nacht ca meine gesundheit
geht gerade komplett den bach runter
deswegen entschuldige ich mich dafür
dass man dass man also dass es geht los
ich habe diese spiele ausgesucht wo wir
auch wir können die kamera tatsächlich
dieses spiel ist forklift man es gibt
ein control menü wo wir wir haben dort
nicht wirklich eines 11 was tue ich hier
das taking pictures
was ist das war ein kriegsschiff
so mache ich definitiv auch marcel feist
was ist denn das was spiele hier das
hier solle ich muss mal kurz die kamera
erinnern das ist der totale ekelhaft
hero mein gott hat der klapprige füße
wir müssen hier irgendwas nehmen
ich glaube so sollte man es nicht machen
die da oben rein stehen
ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher wo ich das
spiel gesehen habe ich glaube bei surf
ich was ist denn jetzt schon wieder mit
der kamera hier los ist hat in amerika
eh schon jeder youtuber gemacht ich
glaube in deutschland nicht bei surf
gesehen und ich jetzt ist ich hab' ich
hab mich echt ein bisschen gesagt
ehrlich gesagt angst vor ihm hier der
macht mir auf jeden fall hat angst vor
allem wenn er dann es ist so ekelhaft
man nehme jetzt mal diesen blicken klotz
4 und packte den
das da sollte er auch hin ich bin mir
nicht sicher wo ich denn hin packen muss
ich versuche einfach mal so musste er
denn jetzt hin ich verstehe dich scheiße
ja schon wieder nach oben sind die
ganzen teile das ist dabei glaube ich
nur lampen und die hier müssen
das ist doch falsch oder meine rein
theoretisch muss ich den klotz auch
einfach nur nach hinten hin setzen damit
ich dem weg habe um
nein das ist definitiv nicht die lösung
ich bin grad mal im zweiten level und
weiß nicht wo ich die teile irgendwie
dran packen soll bei allem respekt ich
sehe es komplett ein dass sich in diesem
level hier vorne wirklich hier oben
einfach den blöcken packen musste um
dadurch zu kommen aber hier hinten ist
ja nicht mal so ein loch kann es
theoretisch sein dass ich die blöcke hey
komm ich habe jetzt einfach mal probiert
die blöcke hier wirklich so hinzustellen
dass ich über die einfach mal drüber
hüpfen kann
und du kommst
egal was geht man ist eigentlich durch
das ist ein puzzlespiel oder was ich
dachte dass der song creep spiel wo ich
cool irgendwie so service machen kann
wir machen das ganze mal in der first
person perspektive das erinnert mich da
ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen an eine
schützende version von mirror's edge ich
plötzlich diesen blog jetzt einfach mal
das habt ihr gar nicht gesehen effekt
rino foschi drm right now
hier ist auf jeden fall noch eine box
die wm wie man mitnehmen ich komme der
steuerung echte ich richtig klar oh mein
gott
ich will ihn auf keinen fall nochmal von
indian wells ecken slater ich hab den
blog jetzt einfach mal dorthin gestellt
ich weiß es nicht
klasse aktion luca wie muss man erstmal
irgendwie in der lage darüber werden wie
ich das ganze hier bestreiten will die
soll ich da den hochkommen diese lücke
der pisa create vielleicht ist es gerade
einfach zu spät räumt aber ein respekt
ich würde gern weiter probieren ich habe
ja auch diesen geist dass sich das jetzt
schaffen will aber ich bin tot ist
fertig und müde deswegen freunde wenn
euch das video gefallen hat würde ich
mich über eine bewertung freuen wenn ihr
noch mehr von mir und dem typen da
irgendwie haben wollt dann schreibt man
die kommentare und schreibt vielleicht
lösungen oder so ich dachte wirklich es
werden city spiel aber es ist
tatsächlich ein puzzle-spiel wir sehen
uns herein eine sache gibt es noch zu
sagen ich habe das bisher nur auf
twitter und snapshot gesagt aber dieses
shirt hier aus dem lokal falsch rum hier
lukasz ob das tasche shirt in schwarz
und das taschen shirt in graue da es gab
nur noch der restbestand da das ist auch
schon in mehreren größen mal wieder
ausverkauft weil er einfach krank sei da
haben wir jetzt noch die letzten sachen
da danach wird es diese stellt nie
wieder geben das heißt wenn ich denke
das ist nice kauft es jetzt weil danach
ist es einfach filmer weg das wollte ich
noch kurz sagen batterie ist immer die
shop adresse